[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
stat of the day brought to you by panini
america the official trading cards and
nfts of the dan patrick show update the
poll results more phone calls coming up
by the way i went outside the traeger
grills and tyler is smoking the brisket
for tomorrow he said it's 24-hour smoked
brisket oh buddy and i said to doug
gottlieb our good buddy wrong day to
come in you miss out on the brisket and
meet friday i i would stay but uh me and
seton had a discussion um
my i have a daughter who she's a
talented bassist bass guitarist okay and
so uh i surprised her with tickets to
see primus tomorrow in long beach
california les claypool famous if you
know base or um
or too many puppies uh anyway so i would
love to stay for meat friday and i am
kicking myself but if you need anybody
to test
i could i don't think it's going to be
ready i just don't think it you know
it's 24 hours i know i know
i know i saw you got a notebook here
you've got notes here well i just i
don't want to screw it up i mean it's a
big thing in the new man cave i've never
been this is incredible okay is this how
would you label this draft
um this is as good a draft as we've had
since i've been doing it and i've been
doing it since 2002 2003 yeah i think
2003 is my first draft i did uh for for
the mothership okay but what makes this
such a great draft you have the
potential of stars at the top then you
have a good group of players in which i
think there'll be a couple emerged as
stars and then you have a great depth of
players but you also have
i even think within that first round
you know there's like a jeremy sohan's a
kid out of baylor
um who fits
not necessarily what a superstar would
look like but a and i don't want to call
him draymond green because he's probably
going to be more talented offensively
but those super talented rollish star
players jalen williams from arkansas
like guys that you're going to see in
the playoffs for the next
you know somewhere in the next 10 years
i think you have just about everything
yet young players are going to develop
you have uh
some older players a couple of foreign
players but that's not really the thrust
of this draft i just think it's the
depth of overall talent and then you get
down the second round and you have some
classic guys who you think
if they lose some weight if they fit an
nba scheme if they buy in they improve
their shooting they're going to be those
i i just this is a really really good
draft i mean there's i don't know did
you see notre dame play they have a kid
blake wesley he's awesome downhill
combo guard like he's gonna go maybe
late first maybe second round that's a
steal compare that to other drafts we've
had where guys are just rushing in the
process and we don't know we have i
think this is a really really deep solid
draft with star potential at the top
we'll talk about that potential here in
a moment let me give the official
introduction uh host of the doug
gottlieb show on fox sports radio
basketball analyst westwood one uh
studio analyst
uh you know when we start to look at
talent and drafting talent it you know
we have leagues that are copy cat
leagues like when the greatest show on
turf the rams everybody's like we're
gonna be like the rams we have to have
the personnel to be like the rams golden
state well golden state drafted most of
these players and can you see teams that
are going to maybe move away from
let's try to get two or three superstars
or can you build in the draft oh i think
you can build a celtics are built
through the draft yeah uh i think you
absolutely if you're smart um and i
thought danny ainge was exceptionally
smart i think brad stevens is smart and
obviously what golden state and bob has
done is brilliant
i the golden state thing in terms of
copying it i don't think you're going to
see that replicated you have to you have
to think about the the two unicorns you
have it's not just that they're two
talented stars that cheer root for each
other's success and everybody else
that's rare but i do think that you'll
occasionally will come upon those guys
but it's that they stayed in college for
three years of peace and they stayed
because they were kind of underrated and
undervalued they also grew up in
basketball households and played for
savant-like motion offensive coaches so
what they do they move without the
basketball we don't teach that in
basketball i have a youth program like
i'm trying to teach them but no one
plays that way everything is with the
ball downhill and if you don't have the
ball it's about spacing and
understanding where you're supposed to
be for the next pass and the next pass
you're not moving and reading a screen
you know the way that you did when you
were when you were a player right like
those days are motion offenses it's not
dead but it's pretty dormant in youth
basketball and high school basketball
especially college basketball so i i
don't think you can replicate that in
how they play but i do think you can
replicate some aspects of it which is
understanding and i said at the time
when they when they traded for andrew
wiggins i thought it was a home run
you know it's not a home run and it's
what and look nick wright has eaten is
has politely eaten his words because
i've heard him on your show and he
destroyed the trade but he was viewing
it from the wrong lens right he's
viewing it from do you want andrew
wiggins to have the ball decide game
seven an nba fight like no but he didn't
have to do that with the warriors right
he's the fourth option he doesn't have
to carry the burden of anything he just
go play and when he played that's what
changed in that series like he started
to play they won the series so again but
it's about finding the right roles and i
think you have some guys and i think
that's what you can do
if you're trying to copy golden state is
can you draft a guy and i know in the
nfl they say don't reach for a need it's
not necessarily a need but putting
somebody in a position to best succeed
and that doesn't mean drafting them and
handing them the basketball to be
something that they're not good enough
at the top of the league and i think
that's the part that you can copy that's
why you might
to jaylen williams or jeremy sohan
because though they don't have as much
god-given talent to score it's all the
other things that actually help you win
and you start to look at need
and need over talent
and i always go i just want a guy who
can play because basketball is
positionless now now you just can you
play jaden ivy i don't know what
position but he can play
now
somebody might go well we have too many
guys at that position
where do you stand on need versus talent
well
yes you can play but here's the big
thing okay can you guard multiple
positions that's a huge thing like what
like wiggins
right but any of these guys okay so like
look at golden state they have one guy
who's not particularly good defensively
and then jordan pulls the other and
steph for his lack of size and strength
he does try so that helps him but but
you got to hide him right he doesn't
switch
you can't hide too it's really hard to
get hard to have smaller players and one
of the things we make a big mistake on
as fans and i think sometimes as
analysts we only look at one side of the
floor the guy can't guard anybody he
can't play in this league he has you
have to be so good on offense
uh james harden right it'll be so good
and james harden is when he was right
was otherworldly and i don't know if we
have a guy like that so when you start
getting past these superstar potential
guys if you can't guard
you can't play so that just like crosses
you off the list right that's i mean
that that was a that's still been a
limiting factor with jordan poole is he
didn't guard anybody and he's getting
better at it but he still doesn't really
guard anybody so you can have one of
those guys that guy better be your best
player you know so i i think yes i don't
think you have to worry about positions
per se
but there are technically positions like
the question for chet holmgren he's got
incredible what's called functional
length you know what that is
well he can handle he can no well
functional so everybody thinks about
like your wingspan yeah okay in
basketball or sports your functional
length is from your elbow to the top of
your fingertips right if you put your
elbows next to your stomach he has
unbelievable functional length so that
allows him to just get his hands on
basketballs deflect things it's gonna
allow him to get his shot off more often
like all of those things are important
is he a is he a five where he defends
the rim
and he's in drop coverage
probably but he's so light and so thin
and what does he look like when you put
25 pounds on him because he has narrow
shoulders and a little bit of a hunch
back he has all the check marks in terms
of competitiveness and skill and length
and i think he'll shoot the ball better
at the next level but i wonder where
that size goes and his shoulders are
really narrow and do people want to
compare him to kevin durant like okay
kevin durant's also a unicorn but he's
always handled it better and frankly
kevin was a better rebounder at texas
and a better shooter score so i don't
think that's the comparison so
yes you want guys that can play but you
got to be able to guard somebody you got
to figure out you know there's really
two positions defensively right which is
you're either defending the rim or
you're one through four you're switching
everything so you have to be one you
have to be able to fit into that in
terms of positions and then you gotta be
able to shoot
if you can't shoot you better be able to
get that rim and the ivy thing is
interesting because he can really guard
really guard great athlete gets the rim
improving shooter but he can make up for
because he's such a freak athlete his
thing is
can he be a leader of a team because
he's fairly quiet if you watched purdue
play he was almost set aside from the
rest of him he didn't feel like he was
in on the purdue thing that was a little
bit weird i i like him a lot i don't
need him to be a leader i just want him
to be a con you know klay thompson's not
a leader they just shows up and plays
yes but but clay also doesn't have the
ball all the time right there's a
difference like if you have the ball all
the time there is a certain leadership
aspect to it you are who your best
player is jayden's going to demand the
ball and he's probably gonna take the
best defensive assignment defensively i
think he'll be really really good i'm
just my only con two concerns with him
is his shot is not
it it he's really improved it and that's
a big thing from one year one to year
two yeah it takes him a little while but
it's more the interacting
he's he's a little standoffish in terms
of personality wise that's nitpicking
he's going to be a
fourth or fifth or i know i know indiana
he will not get past sixth and they'll
probably do everything in their power to
move up again would you take homegrown
number one no if
no i take jabari one okay no matter who
that team is
i mean
because jabari is a guy who you can you
can play anywhere yeah chet a little bit
more limited but look chad has an
incredibly high ceiling
probably a lower floor i think the
question is number two really it's
apollo or chet paulo is like
he's a little bit older but he's ready
now ready now he's ready now he's you
don't even need the microwave just throw
him out there he's ready to go and he'll
get you buckets great body but is he
better than jabari
uh i think he's a little bit better now
i think jabari though has a higher
ceiling and jabari has all those other
check marks all right let me get a
couple of uh we're talking to doug
gottlieb uh the nets situation how does
this end
i mean i i i think i think they i don't
know
um i think they go as they are i think
they try one more shot
with as they're currently constructed
you know but that comes down to does
kyrie opt in because they're not i don't
think they if you listen to sean marx's
words all of those things he said he
wanted guys that are committed right
guys that show up they play for each
other that was direct shots across the
ballot who kyrie is
and
you know i i just and he's not kyrie's
no dummy and he does these guys take
everything personally if he doesn't take
it personally he says okay i'll show
everybody but you i thought you pointed
out well like kyrie's he's a wild card
like no literally no one has any idea
what he's thinking or what he's doing
nothing surprises me anymore no he's
tyson zone right doesn't isn't that the
the ever they're the tyson zone that's a
bill simmons bill simmons deal where
there's no story about mike tyson you
wouldn't believe to be true oh right
that's like rodman zone too right same
thing yeah right well the same thing
with with uh with kyrie there's nothing
he would do that would surprise you can
the lakers stand pat
and and be a playoff a damaging playoff
team
no
no that thing is a disaster with russell
westbrook don't let anybody tell you
otherwise they can soft-sell it if that
destroyed the entire fabric of that team
because
it was a choice that lebron made right
they were going to get buddy healed they
said no no no we want control over this
thing
okay they and they they met with several
players it's been well documented demar
derozan thought he was going there they
hand-picked russell westbrook and then
when they figured out russell westbrook
can't play and they can't can't play
with them
and they distance themselves like he was
on an island last year and you know how
lebron acts like when lebron's done with
you
he's done with you right there's no like
interacting he doesn't he doesn't like
he's not confrontational he's just not
india and he ain't into him so no they
can't stay why did they have to trade
for him to realize that he couldn't play
i don't know
i don't like it's a
whoever whoever okayed that decision
they they all should be gone but they're
not and they they they fired frank and
you know frank was a good enough coach
to win him a championship and then they
destroyed everything that he built it
was mismatched parts didn't but the the
biggest part was that you had russell
westbrook and he wouldn't defend he
couldn't shoot he wouldn't buy into
defensive rotations he wasn't a good
teammate and when they were in the
bubble they had incredible culture
that's why they won not because they
were the best team
so what do you do with westbrook
i would trade him i would i mean
or you know buy him out and stretch him
you know that's what he did with all
dang and that's why he did it with louis
deng because he didn't want to round
yours he's still getting paid no i think
he's just now off the bus okay but but
who wants russell westbrook no nobody
yeah nobody i mean there's talk that
oklahoma city might because they need
they need the salary right they're so
far underneath the salary cap
i just i don't i don't see that one i i
see that being poisoned to the young
guys they're trying to build around
i mean what does it say about houston
that they are and polly pointed this one
out right that he's played what is it 60
games now john wall in three years and
you know they'd rather him not be around
the team and pay him 45 now 47 million
dollars that's crazy then play it's
crazy it's the greatest country on earth
uh kevin durant looking at what steph
curry just accomplished and and what is
uh katy 34 yeah
so
do you think it takes away from kd yes
why
well he had to join staff steph won
without him twice
steph finally got his finals mvp we saw
the you saw the fight i had a second one
you saw the two finals right
he was in three yeah who's the best
player on the floor kd okay that's with
lebron james he was the best player and
then in the finals he got hurt in they
were floundering kd plays one half of
one game before getting hurt he was the
best player so like i i get it like look
steph's incredible
and it does and and part of it is kd
takes everything so personally but at
some point wouldn't you you're like look
dude i was on that team i was the best
player everybody knew his best player
steph knew he was the best player
american who was the best player now i'm
not on the team and they win it's great
but that takes away from me no it should
just continue to point out how great
they are in that organization is
who's had a better career a better
career
kevin durant
kevin durant like did the olympics not
happen who cares about the olympics i
could have gotten a gold medal on that
team they would not have won if kevin
durant oh they would not have won did
you watch the game who care i was there
at the i know you were covering the
olympia cares about the olympics i'm
just saying look i'm you know that sue
bird's greatest basketball player of of
all time oh you're using the the
olympics i got all i got to throw in the
olympics she's been on what five gold
medal teams like come on
no but but when you're around
when you're around the best players and
they all say you're the best player
barkley was the leading scorer on the
dream team he wasn't the best player who
was the leading scorer who was the alpha
on that team
uh mike was okay so that that's really
the point
he did lead he led the team in scoring
okay i mean look has a better resume
than kd resume i'm not you didn't you
didn't say resume you said you said
who's had a better career that's res
resume is not career yes it is is it
yes how do you define a career i gotta
look at your resume
no i would i would it to me it's more
like like he's led the league in scoring
was it five times he's won he's been the
best player gold medal team he's been a
finals mvp
you know he took oklahoma city to the to
the finals and and with that with that
young crew and and what he did like
going back to last year when hardin was
hurt and kyrie gets hurt as well shocker
here right yeah i mean game seven by a
toe on the line he nearly nearly puts
him through to the nba finals against
the milwaukee bucks like that guy to me
it's like we we just we want to find a
way to diminish things kd's done he's a
great player he's this generation's
cream abdul-jabbar can i hit you with it
right you ready
unstoppable shot much like the sky hook
his pull-up jump shots unstoppable
kind of uncomfortably socially and like
you're pointing out i don't think he'll
ever be truly recognized for as great a
player as he is i think kareem's most
underrated player nba history and i
think i think 20 years from now we'll
probably look back and say the same
thing about kevin durant now the
difference is it's his own decision
right you leave golden state and to to
buy into kyrie and want to play with
friends
um but i think that's much what we're
going to say 20 years from now be like
man you know who's actually the best was
actually kevin durant was the best
player in the league for like a five
year stan span there and then he got
hurt and all this other stuff going on
and like yeah but he didn't do that gets
in the nuance i think that's why he's
this generation's kareem
good to see you can i there's no meats
at all no no there's not do people know
how sick this place is uh
see i think the way they shoot it
because you're sitting there it looks
like the old place yes
this is spectacular yeah
if you have a oklahoma state doug
gottlieb jersey and you want to hang it
in here i have one bone to pick for you
look how long has fritzi been with you
uh
20 years how long has paulie been with
you i don't know
15 okay seton
uh
that's
12 15
12 13. how come they didn't get a part
in uh
in the movie sandler sandler picked up
no no no no no no it's a philly movie
and mclovin's from philly
but if dan patrick calls
oh no no no i don't do that todd fritz i
don't do that
how does todd fritz not have an
appearance in i got him in another movie
but how many movies have i got you guys
in
three i think three movies i just wanna
like this is not for me this is for them
you're better than that i know you
should know the answer before you ask
the question and i've gotten them then
they've been in three movies all of them
yes all of them okay but the sandler's
movie is really really good i know and
you're kind of the gatekeeper that's
what everybody says you're the
gatekeeper so i want to know what fritzy
did because i've been looking at the
guest list and it's been spectacular and
is he trying to get back into the get
back on the movie circuit i don't know
what's going on fritzy's known as the
big segment you know he comes up with
the gas big segment that's his nickname
uh
if you're watching on peacock doug will
be uh putting on a shooting display out
here in the man cave oh we're doing this
again yes as only you can but now you
don't have the low roof yeah well let's
see what you can do
you go down close the door
and then you talk
and we didn't talk about the game he
talked about my free throw shoot
took me on the court this guy never
played basketball
and he'd call denny price who was like
his shooting guru
and he's like we want to get you get you
like like uh
what was the guy played for him for the
sons
kevin johnson no alvin adams not now
them's uh
i'll think of him in the second half
perry no
ricky sober no no i'll think of it a
second anyway he's like
he gets me he gets me like this like
elbows in foot forward here
we're shooting the ball and i was like
literally for an hour shooting freak
goes like that horn a sec
what hap i got to college i got really
big with 160 175
and so i was big and i was a little
tight and i wasn't shooting the ball
well but then he tried to change my shot
you know just because you shot an air
ball
i wasn't shooting well to begin with
i was you know i was freshman not tight
but but how do you get the yips
as anybody but you're a good player i
was in high school a great player well i
knew when it happened
i was playing dominguez that was a great
playoffs because
i'll stay in california i was magic's
all american i was i could play so is
that your career resume
my resume
so can we get submit
the problem was i made them when i was
shooting with like this
that looks like they're out of the 50s
yeah seriously
so then wait so then he sends me after
the season and i i stayed with denny
price okay and brent comes in so i've
been working out with denny for like two
or three days and danny's got my hand in
front of them so this is mark price's
smart yes he used to be his assistant
okay okay and so i'm i'm in the gym and
now i'm shooting like threes like that
right
right and and brent price comes in fresh
out of the nba and he's like what are
you doing
and i go with your dad
wanted me to clean your body hand off
the ball so
[Laughter]
if you were watching on peacock
i put on a shooting exhibition doug
gottlieb took some shots out there
took some shots at me too uh this day in
sports history doug staying with us as
we uh close up shop the doug gottlieb
show later on today at fox sports radio
and a westwood one ncaa studio
analyst today
i shot them all well there yeah really
well all right yeah i did all right all
right i wish i shot the ball uh walter
davis by the way is who john mccloud's
like i want to shoot the ball like
walter davis you get your elbows in
there left foot left hand forward late
great john mccloud yeah
great man yeah he's not a basketball
player
yeah tommy had to shoot a basketball
that's not good not a great idea
uh so what happens tonight any what's
the biggest surprise that happens
tonight with the nba draft in your
opinion uh i think there'll be a
they'll be an all-star trade tonight you
know and that's that's i think the
question right
um you know
the the washington field
that's that's the one that i that you
sit there and go he's already made up
his mind
i don't know i thought that the trade
between detroit and portland was
interesting going back to yesterday
right um
but
i think beale if beal's not going to
resign or is going to sign in trade
with washington it happens tonight so
that that's the one to watch would you
take a big swing if you're golden state
and say because i don't know about these
younger guys i don't know if wiseman can
play
um
you know i i like pool they're going to
resign wiggins but would you take a
swing and try to get bradley beal
would i have to give up
well that's what i don't know what
washington wants in return i would say
yeah i mean i mean like does he want do
they want kaminga and what if you game
kamenga and pool and you got bradley
beal
done
done tomorrow yeah but i don't think
that's going to be enough
for brad for brad beale uh this day in
sports history paulie what do you have
for us 1972 u.s president richard nixon
signed the higher education act title ix
as it's called and 1996 michael johnson
the sprinter broke the 200-meter record
and ran at 19.66
the rockets on this day traded elvin
hayes to the bullets for jack maron
how did that work out
ouch although jack maron great shooter
but uh eleven hayes one of the great
players of all time uh final results of
the poll question there seaton o'connor
dan which sport is the most difficult to
officiate right now football's winning
37 hockey and basketball are tied you
want to weigh in on that dog i i think
basketball is the hardest if
hockey i mean i don't understand half of
it anyway so i mean i watched last night
it was pretty great but yeah but um i
would say between basketball and
football and baseball i think basketball
far and away because there's so much
contact especially the way it's played
now there's so much contact on every on
every play and contact is supposed to be
a foul so it's really hard to determine
and
i get it football's hard but football
there's enough officials and you're
looking at a specific play or specific
area i think football's a little bit
easier if i
you got 30 seconds so i took away the
three-point shot in the nba
who would be the team to beat
um who's got guys who can score uh
probably the lakers
right because you got two guys that can
score to get two monsters down there
yeah
i mean that's an interesting one i mean
do you move it back
do you move it out
my late father thought you you move it
out you expand the court i don't know
how they do that with the seating i just
want to see movement
they do move mm-hmm
they they honestly go in and then you
you kick out they move way more now than
they did go back and watch games 25 30
years ago they actually move way more
now well 25 30 years ago they that that
was uh
well they did basketball they did
isoball i mean when jordan was first in
the league it was iso ball right even
even the triangle is a it's a it has
ball movement but at the end of the day
it's isolation and set spacing so you've
got to
you guys just start going three two one
and i gotta shoot at wherever i'm at if
you missed your team's out of the
tournament you're down one your chance
your best friend let's see so it's a
one-and-done if you miss your accident
the other version of this game is if you
hit this shot like coach k will give you
a scholarship right yeah i mean you got
one shot basically does the only four
eddie sutton will give you one because
he can't give you a scholarship
come on
three uh
just go the other way
um
three
two
one there it is oh no so close so
i
dug three
two
one oh that's all right i don't know if
he got it we're going another round
around how to get it off i don't know
i don't need anything you gotta
[Music]
yeah we're all losers
they're all a bunch of freaking losers
you're all worthless
doug three
two
one
and don't be jumping on your surgically
repaired it's fine now it's a year ago
literally last july your favorite last
july and here you go
yeah a little bit
one more check three
two oh bucket one
[Music]
rich eisen shows up next meet friday
tomorrow my thank you